สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูบีค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคน
แล้วก็สวัสดีครูปุ๊กด้วยนะคะวันนี้เรามา
เจอกันนะคะในวันอะไรวันที่เท่าไหร่คะครู
ปุ๊กอ่าวันที่วันนี้เนี่ยวันอังคารค่ะครู
บี
นะวันที่
9 เดือนมกราคมนะปีพศ
2567 ปีคริตศักราช
ค่ะอแต่ครูบีคะเราไม่ได้ต้อนรับนักเรียน
เข้าห้องเรียนเลยค่ะ
โอ้โหก็ยังไงเราก็อยู่ห้องเรียนเหมือน
เดิมค่ะครูปุ๊กงั้นเราก็ต้อนรับเลยค่ะสู่
ห้องเรียนอะไรคะวันเนี้ยขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะ
คะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทยห้องเรียน
comprehensible ค่ะค่ะเป็นยังไงดีใจมั้ย
คะได้มาเจอกับครูบีเพราะว่าครูบีก็ไม่ได้
เจอครูปุ๊กนานนะคะจนปีนี้เนี่ยเป็นปีอะไร
นะคะออ้ก็เป็นปีใหม่แล้วค่ะนะที่เรามาเจอ
กันนะหลังจากเราไม่เจอกันมาเป็นเดือนนะอื
นะเกือบเดือนเลยเนาะใช่พุทธศักราช
2567 แล้วค่ะหรือปีคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะนะเป็นเดือนที่ 1 นะมกราคมค่ะนะ
วันนี้ก็มาถึงวันที่ 9 แล้วเดือนมกราคมนะ
คะปีก็เปลี่ยนแล้วนะคะอ่าเพว่าครูปุ๊กบอก
ว่าตั้งแต่ปีที่แล้ว 20  0  2  3 นะคะครู
บีก็ไม่ได้เจอครูปุ๊กนะคะเกือบ 1 เดือนอื
ใช่ค่ะนะเราไม่ได้เจอกันเป็นเดือนเลยค่ะ
ค่ะก็เลยดีใจค่ะที่ได้มาเจอครูบีค่ะนะ
แล้วก็ได้มาอัดคลิปสอนนักเรียนทุกคนด้วย
ค่ะใช่นะได้มาเจอกันแบบนี้เราต้องปาร์ตี้
กันค่ะครูปุ๊กอ้าปาร์ตี้อุ๊ยกินเยอะกิน
เยอะเดี๋ยวอ้วนค่ะ
อยยช่วงปีใหม่ใช่มยอ่าปีใหม่แฮปี้ New
Year เนี่ยครูบีมองไปเนี่ยทุกคนก็
ปาร์ตี้โดยเฉพาะ
ปาร์ตี้อันเนี้ยนะคะหลายๆหมู่บ้านหลายๆ
บ้านเนี่ยมีงานปาร์ตี้ต้องไปซื้ออันนี้
ค่ะครู
ปุ๊กซื้ออะไรคะต้องไปซื้อหมูค่ะเอามาทำ
หมูกระทะบาร์บีคิวโอหเมนูต้มยำหมูหมู
บาร์บีคิวข้าวผัดหมูโอ้โหอ่ะเนาะคนไทยก็
ชอบกินหมูนะแล้วก็วันนี้ครูปุ๊กก็กินกิน
หมูเหมือนกันค่ะครู
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
บิไหนครูปุ๊กบอกว่ากินมากๆอ่ะมันไม่โอเค
เดี๋ยวเราจะอืมอืม 1 วันเนี่ยเรากิน 2
ครั้ง 2 มื้อพอแล้ว
อืเพราะว่าถ้าเรากินหมูมากๆเนี่ยเดี๋ยว
เราจะอ้วนใช่มย
อืก็ต้องเนาะสำหรับบางคนเค้าก็อาจจะแบบ
เลือกกินแล้วแต่เนอะก็ออกกำลังกายเอ้อถ้า
ไม่อยากอ้วนก็ไปออกกำลังกายไปฟิตเนสอ่า
ใช่นะอแต่ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยก็ชอบกินหมูไงครูบี
เออแต่ว่าถ้าพูดถึงหมูเนี่ยเวลาที่เราจะ
กินเมนูที่ทำมาจากหมูมันมีเมนูเยอะมากนะ
ครูปุ๊กนะต้องถามก่อนว่าวันเนี้ยูครูปุ๊ก
บอกว่าก็กินหมูเหมือนกันแต่มันเป็นเมนู
อะไรอ่ะคะอ๋อเป็นเมนูข้าวขาหมูค่ะูบีโอ
เมนูนี้เนี่ยมันเป็นเมนูที่มีชื่อเสียง
มากนะคะอ่าหลายๆคนจะรู้จักเลยข้าวขาหมูโอ
พูดแล้วอยากกินเลยค่ะครูปุ๊กหูค่ะตอน
เนี้ยอร่อยค่ะนะใช่ค่ะมันเป็นอาหารที่
เค้าเรียกว่าอาหารจานเดียวก็คือคุณสามารถ
กินแบบข้าวสั่งข้าวขาหมูเลยแล้วก็มีข้าว
มีขาหมูใส่ลงมาแล้วก็กินอิ่มอสบายสบายนะอ
เป็นอาหารจานเดียวก็คือถ้าสั่งข้าวขาหมู
มีจานข้าวแล้วก็ขาหมูมาเสิร์ฟคือจบแล้ว
ไม่ต้องรออะไรกินได้เลยใช่ค่ะนะเพราะว่า
ปกติคนไทยก็จะกินข้าวแล้วก็มีกับข้าวกับ
ข้าวกับข้าวหลายอย่างไงนะแต่
เวลาใช่หรือว่าเวลาเราูปุ๊กถ้ามีข้าวมี
ต้มยำกุ้งมีแกงเขียวหวานอันนี้เบื่อค่ะ
แล้วก็ต้องใช้เวลาใช่มยมีข้าวเสร็จแล้ว
ต้องรอต้มยำกุ้งรอแกงเขียวหวานอืเอ่ามัน
เสียเวลาค่ะชอบเร็วๆเร็วๆนะต้องไปคร้าน
แบบนี้เลยค่ะเพราะว่ามันสั่งแป๊บเดียว
เพราะว่าตอนกลางวันเนาะเราเนี่ยสามารถ
ต้องกินเร็วๆค่ะนี่ค่ะร้านแบบนี้เลยค่ะ
ถ้านักเรียนเห็นเนาะก็จะเห็นเนี่ยเค้าไม่
ได้ต้มในหม้อธรรมดาค่ะส่วนมากเนี่ยเขาจะ
ใช้กะละมังเลยค่ะใหญ่ด้วยนะครูปุ๊กใช่นะ
ทุกร้านค่ะข้าวขาหมูเพราะว่าข้าวขาหมู
เนี่ยมันใหญ่นะมันก็เลยต้องใช้เอ่อ
กะละมังค่ะอืมอนะเพราะว่าเวลาต้มใช่มยมัน
ก็จะใส่กะละมังได้นะแต่แต่ถ้าใส่กระทะใส่
หม้อหม้อเนี่ยมันเล็กต้องเอากะละมังใหญ่ๆ
เอาขาหมูเข้ามาวางได้เออใอย่างเงี้ยมันจะ
ได้หลายๆขาไงูบีดถ้าเป็นหม้อธรรมดามันจะ
เล็กใส่ได้ 1 หรือ 2 ขาก็เราทำขายไม่ได้
ทำกินโอเคนะแต่ถ้าทำขายเนี่ยเต้องเป็น
กะละมังใหญ่ๆค่ะเพราะว่ามันจะมีอย่างอื่น
ที่ใส่มาด้วยอ่ะอย่างเช่นนะเขาคก็จะต้ม
หลายอย่างเนาะในในในกระในกะละมังเมื่อกี้
นะก็จะมีทั้งพวกคากินะพวกไข่นะอันนี้ขา
หมูน่ากินมั้ยล่ะคะ
เออนะใหญ่มากนะมีขาหมูนี่อืนะครูุกให้ดู
ส่วนของขาหมูก็คือส่วนนี้ค่ะนะขาหมูข้าว
ขาหมูเขาคก็จะเอาแต่ขาหมูแต่ส่วนเนี้ย
ส่วนล่างเนี่ยเขาจะเรียกว่าคากิ
อือันเนี้ยก็จะเป็นข้าวคากิหรือบางคนชอบ
ชอบกินที่มันไม่ได้มีเนื้อเยอะนะอแต่ว่า
มันจะอร่อยมันจะเหนียวๆเป็นเอ็นน่ะค่ะ
เดี๋ยวครูุค่อยให้ดูเนาะก็คือข้าวขาหมูก็
จะเป็นส่วนของขาจะไม่มีจะไม่มีสันคอจะไม่
มีไม่มีสันคอไม่มีอะไรเนื้อสันนอกสันใน
สะโพกไม่มีซีกโครงนะไม่มี 3 ชั้นด้วยนะคะ
ก็คือเป็นขาหมูอ๋อเข้าใจแล้วทำไมเรียก
เมนูว่าข้าวขาหมูเพราะว่าใช้ขาหมูจริงๆ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็ส่วนที่เ้าตัดมาก็จะเป็น
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะอันเนี้ยค่ะเห็นมั้ยแล้ว
ส่วนของคากิก็จะเป็นนี่อันข้างล่างนี่
คากิอืนะก็คือตรงนี้เขาก็จะตัดเข้าใจแล้ว
ค่ะครูปุ๊กส่วนที่เป็นคากิคือมันไม่ได้มี
เนื้อเนื้อหมูเนาะมันเป็นเหมือนมีมี
กระดูกมีเอ็นใช่มั้ยฝั่งทางด้านนี้นะคะ
ที่ครูปุ๊กใช้เมาส์ชี้อยู่นะคะใช่ค่ะนะ
เพราะว่าส่วนเนี่ยมันก็จะเป็นขาหมูก็คือ
จะเป็นส่วนนี้เลยที่เขาจะซื้อมานะอืเนี่ย
ค่ะแล้วเวลาต้มเนี่ยเขาคก็จะแบ่งตัดออกมา
ค่ะตัดส่วนที่เป็นนะข้างบนข้างล่างเนาะ
คากิอืนะส่วนคากิเขาคก็ขายแพงด้วยนะครูบิ
แปลว่าคนชอบกินบริเวณที่เป็นคากิใช่จริงๆ
มีกระดูกเยอะนะเราต้องแบบดูดๆเอาค่ะอนะ
แล้วก็มีเอ็นที่มันเหนียวๆอแต่ว่าก็มีคน
ชอบเยอะแล้วก็อ้าวเดี๋ยวนะอันนี้ค่ะแล้ว
ก็มีส่วนของไส้ค่ะครูบีอืมที่คนกินกันนะ
ก็จะมีไส้เล็กค่ะลำไส้เล็กของหมูแต่อัน
นี้ต้องล้างทำความสะอาดให้ดีนะนะแล้วก็จะ
มีส่วนของลำไส้ใหญ่อืก็คือเป็นไส้ของหมูอ
ไส้เล็กไส้ใหญ่นะคะใช่นะเขาก็จะต้มไปด้วย
กันค่ะในนี้เลยค่ะนะต้มลงไปด้วยกันทั้งขา
หมูนะแล้วก็ไข่แล้วก็มีคากิมีเอ่อไส้อืโอ
ไม่น่าลกกะละมังใหญ่มากนะคะมีตั้งหลายขา
เห็นมั้ยมันจะได้ต้มได้หลายๆขาเพราะว่าขา
หมูเนี่ยต้มนานค่ะครูบีต้องใช้เวลานานนี่
ค่ะส่วนของคากินะอออันนี้จะเห็นได้เลยว่า
ส่วนที่เป็นคากิใช่มเป็นขาหมูที่เป็นคากิ
เนี่ยมันจะมีกระดูกเนาะมีค่ะกระดูกแล้วก็
จะมีหนังอืหนังที่มันจะมันๆเนาะนะแล้ว
แล้วก็ครูบีชอบกินไส้หมูมั้ยคะชอบนะคะก็
กินกินได้นะคะชอบกินไส้หมูนะคะแต่ครูตุ๊ก
เนี่ยไม่ชอบค่ะไม่กินนักเรียนไม่ชอบก็ไม่
ต้องเอาค่ะใช่เเพราะว่าถ้าเป็นไส้หมู
เนี่ยบางคนชอบบางคนไม่ชอบเนาะอือือใช่ค่ะ
แล้วเวลาเนี้ยก็คือเขาจะเอามาพักไว้แล้ว
ก็อ่ะก็จะมีส่วนของไส้อืมีไข่มี
คากิมีขาหมูแล้วก็จะมีผักนะผักอยู่ 2
ชนิดเนาะนะแล้วก็มีพริกมีกระเทียมนะแล้ว
ก็มีน้ำจิ้มค่ะอืนี่ค่ะ N นะส่วนของ N
เนี่ยแหละค่ะที่จะแพงหน่อยนักเรียนเห็น
มั้ย
อ่าโอเคนะในส่วนของคากิเนี่ยจะมี n เยอะ
ค่ะเอ็นเนี่ยคือเวลาเรากินนเข้าไปใช่มย
เคี้ยวเนี่ยมันจะกึดกึดึดคือมันก็อร่อย
ไงนะคะมันก็เลยแพงนะคะอืมันมีน้อยด้วย
แหละครูบีนะแล้วก็อันนี้ค่ะโอ้โหน่ากิน
มั้ยครูบีอคากินะคะอันนี้ใช่แต่ว่าครู
ปุ๊กไม่กิน
ค่ะเพราะว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยไม่ชอบกินหนังของ
หมูไม่ชอบกินมันของหมูชอบกินแต่เนื้อสี
แดงนักเรียนจะชอบเหมือนครูปุ๊กเนาะนัก
เรียนก็ต้องสั่งแบบนาถ้าเราสั่งข้าวขาหมู
มันก็จะได้ทั้งเนื้อหมูหนังหมูนะแบบแบบ
เนี้ยค่ะข้าวขาหมูมันก็จะได้แบบนี้นะอ่า
อันนี้คือเวลาเราจะสั่งใช่่มั้ยก็ต้องรู้
ว่าจะสั่งข้าวขาหมูยังไงเพราะว่าไม่ใช่
ทุกคนชอบกินไส้ไม่ใช่ทุกคนชอบกินหนัง
เหมือนครูปุ๊กเนี่ยไม่ชอบที่เป็นหนังหมู
ใช่นะคะถ้าสั่งข้าวขาหมูก็คือจะมาทั้ง
หนังแบบนี้หรอคะมีเนื้อมีหนังมีผักใช่ค่ะ
รูบีนะจะมีนะผักเนี่ยมีผักอยู่ 2 อย่างก็
คือผักคะน้าอืนะเขาคก็จะเอาไปต้มในน้ำ
นั่นแหละค่ะน้ำต้มน้ำต้มเอ่อขาหมูนั่น
แหละค่ะขาหมอืแล้วก็จะมีผักกาดดองอืนะที่
นักเรียนเห็นนะเนี้ยก็คือนะผัก 2 ชนิดก็
คือผักคะน้าแล้วก็ผักกาดดองนะเขาก็จะใส่
มาแบบนี้ค่ะข้าวขาหมูถ้าเราสั่งธรรมดา
เนาะข้าวขาหมู 1 จานนี่ค่ะใส่จานมาเลยค่ะ
ก็จะได้แบบนี้แต่ถ้าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยครูปุ๊ก
จะบอกว่าเอ่อข้าวขานหมู 1 จานไม่เอาหนัง
ไม่เอามัน
อืมก็จะได้แบบนี้ค่ะเอออันนี้เราสามารถ
สั่งได้เนาะอยู่ที่ว่าเราสั่งใช่มั้ยคะ
ครูปุ๊กบอกไม่เอามันไม่เอาหนังก็คือได้
แต่เนื้อเหรอคะใช่ค่ะหรือเราจะสั่งแบบว่า
ข้าวขาหมูเอาแต่เนื้อแดงอเนื้อแดงก็คือจะ
เป็นเนื้ออย่างเดียวนะไม่ไม่มีมันไม่มี
หนัง
อืนะก็ขึ้นอยู่กับว่าเราสั่งอะไรนะคะเขาค
ก็จะเอามาเสิร์ฟให้เราอ่ะอันนี้หลอคะแปล
ว่าเค้าสั่งยังไงคะถ้าเป็นจานนี้จานนี้ก็
คือข้าวคากินะแล้วก็ไข่ 1 ฟองออ่าต้อง
สั่งด้วยนะไข่เนี่ยเพราะว่าไข่เนี่ยเขาค
ก็จะบวกราคาเพิ่มใช่มั้ยราคาก็จะเพิ่มนะ
เราจะเอาไข่ด้วยเราก็สั่งเพิ่มใส่ไข่นะ
ข้าวคากิใส่ไข่ 1 ฟองค่ะก็จะได้แบบนี้มา
เลยค่ะเพราะว่าคากิเนี่ยเขาไม่ได้แบ่งขาย
เขาต้องขายทั้งชิ้นค่ะนะอืว่าหลายๆคนชอบ
นะคะถ้าเป็นจานนี้นะถ้าใครที่ชอบกินข้าว
ขาหมูคนที่ชอบกินข้าวขาหมูส่วนมากจะสั่ง
คากิใชหลายคนจะชอบหนังไงไม่ค่อยมีใครที่
ชอบเหมือนคูกุกแต่อันเนี้ยเนี่ยก็จะเป็น
แบบข้าวขาหมูนะแล้วก็เอาไส้ด้วยนะเอาไข่
เอาไส้นะก็จะตักไส้ตักไข่ใส่เข้ามาอ่าใน
จาน 1 จานนะคะก็จะได้หน้าตาแบบนี้เนาะใช่
ข้าวขาหมู 1 จานเอาไส้แล้วก็ไข่ด้วยอืม
นะหรือบางคนบอกว่าไม่อยากใส่ราดลงไปใน
ข้าวนะแล้วก็ชอบกินหลายๆอย่างเนาะอือก็
สั่งแบบนี้เลยค่ะทุกอย่างเนาะใส่แบบ
ใส่แยกอ่าแยกข้าวนะข้าว 1 จานแล้วก็เป็น
ขาหมู 1  1 ถ้วย 1 จานเนาะก็จะได้แบบนี้
ใช่มั้ยคะหรือเรียกเป็นกัก็ได้กินเป็นกั
เขาก็จะเอาแล้วก็ข้าวเปล่า 1 จานนะแล้วก็
ขาหมูเป็นกันะเอาไส้ด้วยอื้อหือเห็นมไส้
อยู่ข้างบนนี่นี่อันนี้เป็นเนื้อแดงแล้ว
ก็มีหนังเนาะแล้วก็มีคากิมีผักนะโอครูบี
ชอบมั้ยเนี่ยมีครูบีชอบจานนี้ค่ะถ้าสั่ง
แยกนะคะเพราะว่าไม่กินไส้ใช่มยครูบีกิน
ไส้แต่ไม่กินไส้ที่เป็นเอามาต้มแบบนี้นะ
จะเป็นย่างบาร์บีคิวเออครูบีจะชอบกินแบบ
นั้นนะถ้าเป็นจานนี้นี่ชอบค่ะอืค่ะอันนี้
ก็คือไม่มีไส้เนาะไม่เอาไส้นะเอาขาหมูกับ
คากิอืม
แล้วก็เอ่อไม่เอาเอาเอาเป็นกัปนะอือเป็น
กัปเป็นกับข้าวอ่ะค่ะค่ะเค้าก็จะแยกมาแบบ
นี้ค่ะแล้วก็สั่งข้าวเปล่าต่างหากเนาะ
หรือว่าแบบนี้บางที่เขาคก็จะทำจานเล็กๆ
ไม่ใหญ่มากกิน 1 คนโอเคนะก็อันนี้ก็จะ
เป็นแบบทีูุ่โอเคอนะอันนี้ก็ข้าวขาอันนี้
ก็เป็นกัเหมือนกันแยกแต่เขาอาจจะมีจาน
เล็กจานใหญ่เนาะอันนี้ก็ต้องดูแต่ละที่นะ
ก็อันนี้เขาก็จะแบ่งเป็นจานอันนี้ก็เป็น
คากิค่ะแล้วก็ใส่ไข่อือืมีให้เลือกเยอะนะ
เนี่ยค่ะอันนี้น่ากินมคะอันนี้ก็น่ากินนะ
แต่ว่าครูปุ๊กน่าจะไม่ชอบเพราะว่ามีหนัง
นะมีหนังอ่าอันนี้จะมีทั้งเนื้อแล้วก็
หนังมีไข่แล้วก็มีผักคะน้านะคะน้าผักดอก
ผักอะไรนะผักนดอากาศดองอือันนี้เป็นเป็น
จานเนี้ยจะเป็นเมนูปกติทั่วไปนะบางคนเค้า
ก็จะสั่งเลยข้าวขาหมูก็จะใส่ไข่ใส่ไข่นะ
คะอืนะอันนี้เป็นข้าวขาหมูใส่ไข่อันนี้ก็
เป็นผักเนาะผักที่ 2 อย่างที่เราเห็นแล้ว
ก็ที่เขาจะเสิร์ฟมาด้วยก็คือจะมีน้ำจิ้ม
สำหรับขาหมูค่ะอืมนะเา้าจะน้ำจิ้มไม่
เหมือนอย่างอื่นไม่เหมือนไก่ย่างนะเป็น
น้ำส้มเปรี้ยวๆเผ็ดๆเป็นน้ำจิ้มเฉพาะขา
หมูนะคุณจะเอาไปจิ้มไก่ย่างเนี่ยไม่ไม่
อร่อยนะต้องเป็นกินกับขาหมูนะใช่ค่ะนะ
หรือบางทีเนี่ยนักเรียนจะเห็นเป็นแบบนี้
สีนี้เนาะใช่นะบางทีวางไว้บนโต๊ะนะคะเรา
ก็ตักราดกับขาหมูได้นะคะใช่ค่ะนะเพราะว่า
บางคนเ้าไม่เ้าไม่ได้ใส่ถ้วยมาให้เ้าวาง
ไว้บนโต๊ะบางที่ก็จะมีถ้วยเล็กๆสำหรับให้
นักเรียนตักแบบเนี้ยจานเล็กถ้วยเล็กๆ
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะแล้วก็ตักน้ำส้มเองอืนะเค้า
ก็จะมีขวดไว้ให้เพราะว่าบางคนเนี่ยชอบน้ำ
ส้มเยอะๆนะบางคนชอบน้อยนะเป็นน้ำจิ้มเนาะ
ก็ตักกันเองเลยนะแต่อย่างครูปุ๊กเนี่ยไม่
ไม่ชอบกินน้ำส้มแบบนี้ค่ะนะน้ำพริกแบบนี้
สีแบบนี้แต่ว่าบนโต๊ะเนี่ยมันก็จะมีบางที
นักเรียนจะเห็นเขาจะให้กระเทียมหัวเล็กๆ
ไว้เนาะแล้วก็พริกขี้หนูอืมนะสำหรับกิน
เออคือเมนูข้าวขาหมูเนี่ยถ้าเกิดว่ามี
โต๊ะนั่งนะนักเรียนจะเห็นว่ามีกระเทียม
แล้วก็มีพริกเป็นพริกพริกสดนะเป็นพริกขี้
หนูแบบนี้เลยก็เอาไว้กินด้วยกันใช่มั้ยคะ
ใช่ค่ะบางที่ถ้าไม่มีเขาก็จะเสิร์ฟมาด้วย
กันอย่างนี้ค่ะน
แล้วก็มีกระเทียมมีพริกนะแล้วก็กินด้วย
กันกับขาหมูมันจะเข้ากันอร่อยค่ะเพราะว่า
อันเนี้ยคนไทยชอบกินรสจัดๆไงรสจัดหมายถึง
ว่าเปรี้ยวเผ็ดเค็มหวานมากๆเขาก็จะเติม
พริกเข้าไปเพราะว่าขาหมูเนี่ยมันจะเค็ม
ออกเค็มนะน้ำจิ้มเนี่ยจะเผ็ดกับเปรี้ยวนะ
แล้วก็ถ้าใครคิดว่ามันยังไม่เผ็ดพอก็นี่
เลยค่ะกัดเข้าไปด้วยค่ะกินพริกสดๆกับขา
หมูเนี่มันเข้ากันค่ะอือืนะก็นะเจะมีน้ำ
ส้มมีพริกอะไรแบบนี้มาให้นักเรียนก็เข้า
ใจได้เนาะกินกับขาหมูเนี่ยแหละค่ะนะมัน
เป็นอาหารที่คือเขาจะเป็นเครื่องเคียงที่
กินด้วยกันแล้วเบางที่จะมีวางไว้บนโต๊ะ
เลยเาจะไม่เสิร์ฟเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเขาจะ
เสิร์ฟเฉพาะข้าวขาหมูตามที่เราสั่งเนาอื
นะอันนี้คือเมนูข้าวขาหมูนะใครไม่ชอบกิน
อะไรเนี่ยก็สั่งอย่างที่ครูปุ๊กบอกเนาะ
อ่าใช่นะแล้วก็ต้องดูด้วยว่าอ่าร้านข้าว
ขาหมูเนี่ยอยู่ที่ไหนอ่าไม่ใช่อร่อยทุก
ที่นะครูปุ๊กก็ต้องเดี๋ยวนี้สะดวกสบายตรง
ที่ถ้านักเรียนอยากกินข้าวขาหมูเนี่ย
สามารถเสิร์ช Google ดูได้เลยเนาะว่าร้าน
ที่เขารีวิวใช่มยอ่าแถวไหนอร่อยอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะเราก็สามารถเช็คดูได้นะคะอืแล้ว
ก็ไปง่ายใช่มั้ยอืมีมี Google
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
Map ใช่มยคะก็หากินได้แบบสะดวกสบายนะคะ
ใช่แล้วก็เราจะดูสีไงนะไม่ใช่สีดำมากๆ
เนาะมันจะดูไม่น่ากินมันดูเก่ามันดูไม่
ใหม่ไงนะแต่ว่าร้านที่ครูบุ๊กให้ดูก็น่า
กินนะินะใช่ใช่ค่ะนะแล้วก็ดูหม้อนะหรือ
ว่ากะละมังที่เขาใส่ข้าวขาหมูนะเราก็
สามารถดูได้เพราะว่าร้านข้าวขาหมูเนี่ยก็
คือมันจะโชว์ใช่มยครูปุ๊กนะค่ะอ่าก็คือ
ตั้งโชว์แบบนี้เลยนะคุณก็จะเห็นว่าอ้อ
ข้างในร้านเห็นมั้ยคะก็จะมีลูกค้าเนี่ย
นั่งอยู่ที่โต๊ะเก้าอี้นะคะอ่าสะอาดเห็น
มั้ยคะเราก็เลือกกินได้นะคะอันนี้ก็น่าจะ
มีชื่อเสียงนะร้านที่ครูปุ๊กให้ดูเนี่ยเอ
อยู่แถวๆสาธรด้วยนะคะแล้วก็มีตั้ง 3 สาขา
เห็นมั้ยคะสาขาที่ 3 อืแปลว่าอ่อยค่ะน่า
จะอร่อยค่ะปุ๊กดูจากสีนะอืแดงว่าน่าจะ
อร่อยถ้านักเรียนไม่อยากนั่งกินนที่นี่ก็
ซื้อใส่กล่องได้นะบางทีเา้าก็จะมีกล่อง
ที่เป็นอาจจะเป็นโฟมเป็นพลาพลาสติกเนาะ
แล้วก็มีข้าวใส่แล้วก็เอาขาหมูใส่ลงไปมี
ผักมีอะไรเรียบร้อยนะนน้ำส่วนน้ำพะโล้ที่
เอาไว้ราดน้ำแบบเนี้ยค่ะน้ำข้างในเนี่ยนะ
ราดบนขาหมูเนเพื่อให้มันแบบรสเค็มๆหน่อย
นึงนะเขาก็จะเอาใส่ถุงมาให้ด้วยถ้าเขาเอา
มานะอก็จะอร่อยมากขึ้นค่ะแล้วเวลากิน
เนี่ยต้องมีพริกนะ
อืเคี้ยวพริกเข้าไปด้วยนักเรียนบอกอู้ย
เผ็ดค่ะกินไม่ไหวเออนะก็ไม่เป็นไรนะเพราะ
ว่าบางคนก็อาจจะสั่งข้าวขาหมูมีพริก
กระเทียมถ้ากินเผ็ดไม่ได้เขาก็กินขาหมู
กับข้าวได้นะคะก็อาจจะมีซอสน้ำจิ้มอ่าที่
เขาวางไว้ให้เนี่ยโรยนิดหน่อยมันก็ไม่ได้
เผ็ดนะคะอ่ามันอาจจะออกเปรี้ยวๆเนาะอ่า
ค่ะก็กินด้วยกันแต่ครูปปุ๊กบอกว่าสีเนี่ย
ถ้ามันดำเกินไปก็ไม่น่ากินหรอค่ะใช่ค่ะ
มันจะเหมือนแบบเหมือนต้มแล้วต้มอีกอ่ะอ
เหมือนของ
เก่าแล้วไม่หมดอย่างเงี้ยค่ะแล้วก็ใส่
แล้วก็ต้มอีกต้มอีกเพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วขา
หมูอ่ะมันต้องต้มนานนะอ่าอย่างในรูปเนี้ย
ค่ะกครูปุ๊กกครูปุ๊กลองเอามาให้ดูหน่อย
ค่ะที่เป็นแบบข้าวขาหมูในจานที่น่ากิน
เนาะเพราะว่าตอนนี้มันอยู่แค่รูปเดียวใช่
มยเอาที่เป็นทำใส่จานมาอันนี้ไส้ไม่ใช่
ทุกคนชอบกินนะคะ
อ่าเราอาจจะดูสีจากจากเอ่อในหม้อหรือว่า
ในจานอย่างงี้ลอค่ะใช่สีแบบนี้ก็ดูน่ากิน
นะคะครูปุ๊กใช่อันเนี้ยสีนี้โอเคนะมีเห็ด
ด้วยมีเห็ดหอมด้วยอืนะอ่าอันนี้ก็สีไม่
ได้ดำเกินไปนะนะคะอ่ากำลังดีเนาะนักเรียน
บอกไม่ไม่ชอบอันนี้ค่ะไส้
นะแบบนี้ก็โอเคมยครูบีสีแบบนี้อสีแบบนี้
ก็โอเคค่ะเพราะว่าข้าวขาหมูเนี่ยมันจะมี
สีที่เป็นสีออกดำๆอยู่แล้วนะคะแต่ถ้าดำ
มากๆน่าจะไม่อาจจะหลายวันใช่มั้ย
คะใช่ค่ะก็ต้องดูนะคะนะเค้าก็จะมีแบบนี้
ค่ะแล้วก็ราดน้ำมาด้วยนะอืมค่ะแบบนี้ก็จะ
ดูแห้งๆหน่อยเนาะููคิดว่าเวลานักเรียนกิน
อาจจะ
แบบแยกแยกกับข้าวดีกว่าเนอะมันจะดูน่ากิน
กว่าเนอะแบบค่ะแต่ว่าอันนี้ก็เร็วดีค่ะ
สะดวกดีอันนี้ก็ต้องราดน้ำลงไปเนาะอันนี้
เยังทำให้มันแห้งอยู่ปกติเขาก็จะมีน้ำที่
ราดมาในข้าวหรือว่าราดที่ขาหมูอืมนะนะอัน
นี้ก็ต้องดูนะคะดูดูให้แบบอ่อดูร้านว่า
เอ๊ะข้าวขาหมูเนี่ยขาหมูเนี่ยสีมันเหมือน
เป็นหมูที่ทำมาใหม่ๆมั้ยอืใช่มั้ยคะหรือ
ว่าต้มต้มนานแล้วหลายวันอย่างเงี้ยค่ะนะ
อันเนี้ยใหม่โอเคนะอืมีเอ็นมีอะไรน่ากิน
ใช่มั้ยใช่อย่างที่ครูปุ๊กเอาให้มาดูนี่
คือเป็นรูปที่อ่าโอเคเลยนะคะเป็นข้าวที่
แบบว่าเป็นข้าวแล้วก็ขาหมูที่ยังใหม่อยู่
นะแต่ถ้าเกิดบางบางครั้งเราเห็นแบบขาหมู
มันแห้งมากอย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะเอ๊ครูบีก็อาจจะคิดว่าอันนี้น่าจะกี่
วันแล้วอย่างเงี้ค่ะครูปุ๊กเดี๋ยวครูบีมี
รูปให้ดูได้ค่ะครูบีเพราะว่าเนาะพอดูแล้ว
เนี่ยไม่น่ากินก็เราก็อาจจะแบบไม่อยากชิม
เพราะว่าอะไรเพราะว่ามันอาจจะเค็มก็ได้นะ
นักเรียนนะเพราะว่ามันต้มแล้วต้มอีกต้ม
แล้วต้มอีกเนี่ยนะหลายวันมันก็อาจจะแบบโห
ความเค็มเนี่ยมันจะเข้าไปในเนื้อหมูค่ะ
ใช่แล้วก็สีสีของหมูเนี่ยมันเหมือนแบบต้ม
หลายครั้งนะวันนี้อาจจะขายไม่หมดแล้วหมู
เนี่ยมันก็จะมีจากที่หนังหนังที่มันเป็น
สีออกดำนิดหน่อยใช่มยออกเหลืองๆเนี่ยพอ
ครูปุ๊กเห็นแบบเนี้ยครูปุ๊กจะรู้สึกว่า
อึ้ยอันนี้เหมือนหมูประมาณ 3 วันหรือ 7
วันใช่ม
นะอันนี้ไม่น่ากินเลยนะคะ
เอออันนี้อาจจะผสมกันมั้ยครูบีอันเนี้ยดำ
เห็นมั้ยริมสุดขวามือเนี่ยดำมากนะเหมือน
ไม่ได้ต้มมาหม้อเดียวกันอือาจจะเอาของ
เก่าเนี่ยมาขายก่อนแต่ว่าริมทางซ้ายมือ
เนี่ยก็เป็นของใหม่อยู่นะอ่าตรงนี้ก็อาจ
จะใหม่อยู่นะแต่สังเกตเห็นได้ว่ามันมัน
ไม่น่ากินเนาะเนาะอ่าเนื้อหมูมันเหมือน
มันมันต้มหลายวันแล้วค่ะอันนี้หลายครั้ง
ด้วยนะคะแต่ถ้าอย่างรูปที่ครูปุ๊กให้ดู
เนี่ยเอออันนั้นน่าจะเป็นเนื้อหมูใหม่ๆ
อยู่นะคะก็สังเกตดูได้ไม่ยากนะคะ
อืมอันนี้ข้าวขาหมูนะเป็นเมนูที่หลายๆคน
บอกว่าอร่อยแล้วก็ชอบกินแต่หลายๆคนก็จะ
บอกว่าฉันชอบกินข้าวขาหมูมากแต่ฉันกลัว
อ้วนนเพราะว่ามันจะมีมันเยอะใช่มยแล้วก็
มีหนังหมูใช่มั้ยคะอแต่บางคนเ้าบอกว่าเรา
เนี่ยต้องกินอะไรที่มันมีเอ่อ
คอลลาเจนออคอลลาเจนคอลลาเจนมันทำให้ผิวน
ผิวเราเนี่ยดูดีไม่
เหี่ยวอือ๋อคอลลาเจนนะใช่มีคอลลาเจนนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยบางคนก็บอกว่าไม่เป็นไร
หรอกก็คือเราอยากกินไงอือ๋อฉันกินเพราะ
ว่ามีคอลลาเจนอย่างงี้หรอคะใช่ค่ะเพราะ
ว่าอยากเอาใจตัวเองว่าเวลาเรากินเราจะไม่
รู้สึกผิดไงอย่างกุ๊กกินเนี่ยกูุ๊ก็จะไม่
ชอบกินคอลลาเจนของมันอยู่แล้วผิวหนังหมู
เนี่ยหนังหมูไขมันนิ่มๆสีขาวเนี่ยก็ไม่
กินนะจะกินแต่เนื้อสีแดงเท่านั้นค่ะ
แต่ว่าถ้าเป็นข้าวขาหมูเนี่ยหลายๆคนก็จะ
บอกว่าส่วนที่มีหนังเนี่ยที่เป็นคอลลาเจน
เนี่ยนะครูปุ๊กหลายๆคนชอบไงค่ะอืมเพราะ
ว่าบางคนชอบกินหนังเนาะบางคนชอบกินไขมัน
ของหมูนะเพราะว่ามันจะนิ่มๆอืนะแต่ครูุ
อร่อยครูบุ๊กอ่ะไม่ชอบครูปุ๊กก็้ว่ามัน
ไม่
อร่อยคือครูปุ๊กน่ะไม่อร่อยแต่ 99 คนบอก
ว่าอร่อยอย่างเงี้ยค่ะใช่คือถ้าครูปุ๊ก
อร่อยเนี่ยูปุ๊กคงอยู่เต็มจอละหน้าคูปุ๊ก
น่าจะไปอย่าง
งี้ใช่มยคือถ้าเป็นหนังหมูกินมากๆก็อ้วน
จริงๆนะคะนี่ก็คือบางคนก็เลยบอกว่ามัน
อร่อยนะเมนูข้าวขาหมูแต่ก็ไม่อยากกินเยอะ
ใช่มยคะเวลาที่เราอร่อยเราก็คอนโทรลตัว
เองไม่ได้ใช่มั้ยครูปุ๊กอาจจะกินเยอะๆ
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะใช่ค่ะเราก็จะไม่สามารถควบ
คุมตัวเองได้เพราะว่ามันอร่อยไงนะแต่ว่า
นานๆกินทีนึงก็ดีค่ะเพราะว่าเราจะได้
เปลี่ยนเมนูไปเรื่อยๆเพราะว่าเราก็มี
อาหารเยอะมากอืแล้วมันก็เร็วดีใช่นะแล้ว
ก็อันนี้ครูบีก็รู้สึกว่าเนี่ยถ้าเป็น
ข้าวขาหมูแบบนี้นะคะอ่านักเรียนก็ไปสั่ง
กินได้นะคะแล้วก็แล้วแต่นักเรียนชอบเลยนะ
ชอบแบบมีหนังมีเนื้ออ่ามีเนื้อหนัง
คอลลาเจนโอเคก็บอกเขาว่าข้าวขาหมู 1 จาน
แค่นั้นค่ะเขาจะมาพร้อมกันก็คือมีทั้ง
เนื้อแดงไขมันแล้วก็หนังนะถ้านักเรียนไม่
ชอบกินไขมันกับหนังก็บอกเขาว่าเอาแต่
เนื้อสีแดงใช่มยนะเอาข้าวขาหมูเอาแต่
เนื้อแดงอืเห็นมยก็สั่งง่ายๆเนาะอ่ะไม่
เอาหนังไม่เอาไขมันไม่เอา
คอลลาเจนเราก็สั่งได้ก็คือมันสั่งได้ทั้ง
2 แบบเนาะจะเอาแต่เนื้อแดงก็โอเคไม่เอา
หนังไม่เอามันอืก็โอเคนะหรือใครที่อยากจะ
กินทุกอย่างเนาะใส่เอาไส้ก็บอกเขาว่าข้าว
ขาหมู 1 จานเอาไส้ด้วยเอาไข่ด้วยอืมอหรือ
บางคนบอกว่าเอาคากิด้วยเอาเอาทุกอย่างค่ะ
อือเห็นมก็อร่อยไงก็อยากกินอร่อยก็เลย
สั่งทุกอย่างนะทั้งไข่อ่าเอาไส้เอาคากิ
สรุปแล้วอร่อย
นะไม่ต้องคิดอ้วนไม่อ้วนนะคะถ้าเรากิน
เมนูนี้วันนี้ก็ขอบคุณครูปุ๊กมากๆนะคะที่
มานำเสนอเมนูข้าวขาหมูนะคะแต่ถ้าเราชอบ
เราก็ไม่ต้องกินทุกวันก็ได้ค่ะ 1 อาทิตย์
1 ครั้งก็ได้นะคะหรือว่าก็ไปออกกำลังกาย
ค่ะไปฟิตเนสไปนะไปออกกำลังกายไปยิมไปอะไร
อย่างงี้นะนักเรียนก็จะได้มีสุขภาพที่ดี
ค่ะหุ่นดีโอเคนะอืนะถ้ากินอาหารที่มีไข
มันเยอะเราก็ไปออกกำลังกายอันนี้ก็ต้อง
ควบคุมตัวเองใช่มั้ยคะวันนี้ก็ขอบคุณครู
ปุ๊กมากๆเรา 2 คนต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วนะคะอ่ะ
เอาไว้เจอกันใหม่โอกาสหน้าค่ะครูปุ๊กคลิป
หน้านะคะนักเรียนก็คอมเมเบอกเราก็ได้นะ
ว่านะนักเรียนน่ะชอบกินข้าวขาหมูมยแล้วก็
ชอบกินแบบูปุ๊กหรือชอบกินแบบครูบีนะแล้ว
มาพบกันใหม่ในคลิปต่อไปนะคะขอบคุณค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ